hey Samuel lives here and in this video
I wanted to give you the pros and the
cons of buying properties from auction
so if you're interested or considering
buying properties from auction then stay
tuned so overall I would probably not
advise buying from auction especially if
you're just starting out and if you are
gonna buy from auction then definitely
watch the whole of this video because
I'm gonna give you some tips at the end
about how to buy from auction if you do
so the pros the first pro to buy for
auction is usually if someone's selling
their house on an auction then normally
pretty motivated and we know that the
best deals are from motivated sellers so
just put your house on an auction you're
probably quite motivated so it is
possible to pick up bargain properties
from auctions because you're doing with
motivated sellers second pros there's no
messing around you're not gonna get into
a bidding war the drags on later you're
gonna go down to the auction you're
going to put your best offer forward if
it's not accepted fine if it's accepted
then you've got a certain short time
period complete to complete you're not
gonna get gazhams no messing around
straight to the point which you know
it's quite an attractive aspect of
buying from auction and then thirdly is
it's quite fun you know going down to an
auction there's a lot of excitement it's
quite satisfying when you win in auction
that there's are three pros the cons are
in auction it's usually flooded with
properties not always but properties
that have got something wrong with them
now that's okay if you're experienced
and you can figure out what's wrong with
the property and you can then add value
but if you're just starting out and
you're not that wise to property you can
get burned by buying your property you
can't just pull out you can't go
actually the property's got something
wrong with it I want to pull out if you
do you're gonna get fined badly so
problem properties is definitely a con
if you don't know what you're doing
second con is even if you win at the
auction you're still the loser in fact
the winner of an auction is usually the
biggest loser of them all because
imagine who here is the loser who's
prepared to pay the most money for this
pillow you know there could be if
there's 200 people in the room and
you're the person that's prepared to pay
the most then you're the loser so the
winners of the loser
the losers of the winners in away from
auction so that that's another corner
you're the person for vet to pay the
most
so again unless you're really wise and
you know that you're gonna pay that
amount because you're going about to add
serious value that's another con third
con and possibly the biggest con and the
reason why I advise against auctions the
most people that are starting out the
whole purpose of an auction and the way
it's wired is it's all about emotions
and what they'll do is they'll tap into
your emotions
they'll play you off against other
people to try and manipulate you into
paying the absolute maximum price you
will for that property
I really believe that when emotions are
high and you're excited and emotions are
high intelligence is low and that's
exactly what they want to happen I mean
yeah you've probably heard in my videos
before I say by with formulas not
feelings auctions often all about
feelings they trap because what happens
is because on the day if you buy it
you've got to go ahead then what happens
is before you go you're gonna do your
research you're gonna do a survey on the
property you're gonna probably invest
time and money researching the property
which means that you're now invested so
when you go to the auction you're now
invested your energy and your money's
invested and you really want that house
your end up paying over the odds for it
because you're already emotionally
attached what happens in auction is a
lot of people break the rules of not
being emotionally attached using
formulas not feelings so that the key is
be very very careful if you're buying
from auction often people think you know
oh yeah you Bible hogging properties do
you buy from auction then which is a bit
of a myth a bit of a misconception
I've actually got friends and what they
do is they buy properties that I'll run
down and need a lot of work doing and
they buy them straight up from high
street agents or from Rightmove they do
nothing to them at all they've run down
houses apart from board up the windows
and money them up a bit and make that
even worse they then put them on an
auction and they sell them for more on
an auction than they paid for them from
the high street so getting the bargains
from auctions is actually a little bit
can be a little bit of a myth so I'm
gonna give you a few tips if you are
buying from auction in how to doing what
to do firstly the castle that we owned
we bought from an auction if you're
going to go to an auction have the
maximum price that you're - you're
prepared to pay for that
prophecy in mind before you go and do
not go a pound above that price that
you've said do not go a pound of it
decide in the cold light of day what
you're gonna pay and then do not go up
and above it and that way you've got to
be super disciplined that's the first
tip or piece of advice second which is
really important is buy pre or post
auction not actually in the room and why
would you do that well if there's a
property that's going to auction work
out what you've been prepared to offer
it and then just put that forward to the
veer to the agent just say I'm happy to
buy this before it goes to auction this
is what I'm prepared to pay for it
that's a very good way to pick up
properties host auction is even better
because if you imagine how someone would
feel if they put that property on
auction and they're just desperate to
just get rid of it in one fell swoop
there was 200 people in the room let's
say and it didn't sell it didn't even
hit the reserve price that seller is
gonna have gone from motivated to almost
desperate very very motivated which is a
good time to then come in following
properties that have not sold at the
auction and then come in post auction
that's so another really good way to buy
properties and then a final little tip
around auctions that I've got is if
you're not looking to buy properties but
you're looking to package and sell
properties because maybe you've got no
money no tip that came from my friend
Kenneth Hahn he said that if you're
looking for people to sell properties to
the best place to find them is from an
auction because if you go to an auction
everyone went to an auction because
they've got money because they are
wanting to invest in orbit to buy a
property there's only one winner per
property obviously but there's others
that most people at the end of the
auction have not bought anything and
they're probably feeling very
disappointed but they didn't buy
anything that they missed out so give
her in a room filled with people who
want to buy property who are really keen
have the money people are now really
disappointed because they weren't able
to because they got kazaaam by someone
else what a perfect opportunity to go up
to them and say hey sorry you missed out
I've actually got a deal if you're
interested I can drop you an email if
you've got a card like what an
opportunity to find investors to sell
them your deal so there's a little
golden as well for you guys anyway I
hope that's been helpful please do share
this video if you've enjoyed it don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
hit that notification button so you
never miss
trick again comment your thoughts below
peace out see you next time thank you so
much for watching this video it's
mentoring on a Monday every single week
at 7 p.m. on a Monday between 8 p.m. I'm
gonna be live answering all your
comments and questions don't forget to
subscribe right over here so you'll
never miss one of these videos I'll see
you next week at 7 p.m. also if you
haven't got a copy of my book you need
this in your life you can get it from
Amazon for ten pound ninety nine or a
gift from made absolutely free down
below in the description link I'll see
you next week monday at 7 p.m.